SPEAKER: Good afternoon, everybody.
Thank you for coming.
I am very, very pleased to host
Dr. Tuttle to speak at Google today.
Dr. Tuttle is the author
of the number one
Amazon bestselling book,
The World Peace Diet.
He's an educator, composer,
pianist, and a writer.
He's a peace activist
and a vegan for over 30 years.
And he's the recipient
of the Courage of Conscience Award.
He has a PhD from UC-Berkeley
focusing on educating,
intuition, and altruism.
He's a creator of the World Peace Diet
Mastery and Facilitator Training Program.
And he has taught college courses
in philosophy, humanities,
mythology and comparative religion.
He's a former Zen monk and Dharma master
in the Korean Zen tradition.
He's a co-founder of the Worldwide
Prayer Circle for Animals.
And he's currently conducting
a music, art, and education ministry
with his spouse, Madeleine Tuttle, who is
a visionary artist from Switzerland.
She has her animal paintings
and various other paintings
on display here if anybody
wants to take a look later.
And we'll also have
The World Peace Diet books for sale
here at a subsidized rate.
So without further ado,
I'd like to welcome Dr. Will Tuttle.
[APPLAUSE]
WILL TUTTLE: Thank you.
Thank you so much, Chitanya.
And greetings everyone.
It's good to be with you here,
my first time ever in Google.
And how many of you have actually read
The World Peace Diet,
just so I have an idea?
Have any of you read the book before?
No?
All right, good.
So I'll just talk for a few minutes here
about what I think are
the fundamentally essential ideas.
And then we can have a short time
for Q&A as well.
So the basic idea
in The World Peace Diet,
is that all of us are born into a culture
that has a hidden program
when it comes to food.
And it actually has
a hidden underlying practice
that is really, in many ways,
taboo to discuss.
And how many of you would you say
have taken time somehow,
in some way, to look behind
the curtain of our culture's food system?
The food system in the United States?
Some of you?
A few of you have.
Some of you probably
don't want to do that.
It's quite shocking, I will say.
But the basic idea is,
from my point of view,
the greatest adventure I believe
we can take as human beings
in our culture today is the adventure
of looking behind the curtain
of our culture's food system, and
understanding the ramifications of this
for us as individuals, for our planet,
for our culture, for future generations.
The web of relations that are impacted
by our food choices is enormous.
And the significance of it I think
has been extremely underestimated.
There's a basic idea, I think,
that all of you are familiar with.
In the ancient Greek tradition, there was
- over the temple of Delphi a saying,
'gnothi seauton'.
That means "know thyself."
The basic idea is that in order for us
to live lives of meaning, and purpose,
and authenticity, we have to make
an effort to understand ourselves.
And I think we all understand.
Also, if we want to understand ourselves,
we have to understand the culture
that we're raised in.
Because in many ways,
we live in a culture,
but that culture lives in us.
So for us to understand ourselves,
we need to understand
the programming of our culture,
the underlying assumptions
and the basic mentality of our culture.
Because we're like little sponges
when we land here on this planet
and we start learning,
and learning the language,
and learning what people eat,
and what they do,
and what you don't do, and all of that.
It's enormously powerful programming.
And so to understand our culture,
the most powerful way
-- and anthropologists understand this.
If you want to understand a culture,
deeply, directly,
quickly look at their food.
Because food is the most powerful
ritual in any culture.
It's the primary way that in any culture
the values and norms are passed
from generation to generation.
It's through the food rituals.
And so when we look deeply into food,
we're looking really, in many ways,
at the core of our culture's
underlying assumptions
about the nature of reality that
have been injected into all of us.
That are, in many ways, invisible.
So what I'd like to talk about today is,
essentially, the ramifications
of our food choices.
And that they are much more vast
than we imagine.
Not only the ramifications in the outer
world, like the Earth and in our culture,
but specifically the ramifications
in the inner world.
What does it do to us,
from the psychological, spiritual,
emotional, and these levels as well?
So The World Peace Diet
is probably the only book,
at least in English,
that goes into this inner dimension
of our food choices in this way.
So what I'd like to do I guess is just--
because the basic dilemma I have,
in many ways, in putting on
a lecture like this,
The World Peace Diet is available
over here at an amazing price.
Madeleine said it's only $5.
Normally it's $22.
We do have audio books.
And we have a special price, actually,
on the audio books
You can see us afterwards. It's me
basically reading the entire book.
It takes 13 and 1/2 hours for me to read
The World Peace Diet pretty quickly.
And I would like to give you
as much as I can of that.
So I'll be speaking faster and faster
as time goes on here.
So much I want to share with you,
and there really isn't enough time
to give this big picture.
But the basic idea is to understand
at least the main part of this puzzle.
And the essential idea
that's basically unnegotiable is
that in the United States alone, right
now, by a very conservative estimate,
we are killing
75 million animals for food.
That is routinely and relentlessly
happening every single day.
There's no big headline
in the New York Times
saying, wow, 75 million animals
were somehow killed yesterday.
I think it is huge news.
It's probably the biggest news actually,
in our entire culture.
But because it's happening every day,
routinely and relentlessly like I said,
it's just not news.
Cause this is something that's happening
because we, the people, are choosing.
We're taking out our wallets and saying,
I want the flesh of animals for food.
Or in many cases, the dairy products
and eggs are secretions of animals.
And so we don't realize
that this has an enormous impact.
By killing 75 million animals
a day for food, means essentially
that we have put into place we have built
a massive industrialized killing machine
that reaches its tentacles into every nook
and cranny of our outer world,
from the bottoms of the oceans,
deep in to the Amazon Rainforest,
and everywhere on this planet.
As well as very, very deeply
into our own internal landscape
of our feelings, and thoughts,
and yearnings and mythology
within ourselves as individuals
and as a culture.
So if we begin to understand this,
if we begin to understand
the ramifications of killing 75 million
animals every day for food,
we begin to understand, I believe,
why we have the problems
that we have as a culture.
And why we are so essentially inept
at solving them.
Why we just don't exhibit
very much intelligence at all
or creativity because of the food.
The food program is injected
into every one.
And basically, when we leave here,
we go outside.
We see people eating meat,
dairy products, and eggs.
We have to realize that obviously,
the only reason anyone does this
is because of the culture
they're born into.
This culture essentially gives us this
as what we are told to do.
I remember as a little kid
growing up in Massachusetts,
I was about maybe seven years old.
And I said to my mother, Mom,
the kind of foods we're eating,
is this what everybody eats?
And we were eating lots of meat,
dairy products, eggs, typical meals.
And my mother said, 'Yeah.
This is what everybody eats.'
And I said, OK, thanks.
And she came back a little while later
and said, well, actually,
there are vegetarians.
And she said that word
in a way that I knew
that these people lived on another planet.
She said, I've never met one.
You'll never meet one either.
They're kind of like hypothetical people.
Where would they get their protein?
They couldn't possibly exist.
So that was the reality I grew up with.
And my mother was totally right.
I never met a vegetarian
my whole life growing up.
Or even heard the word again.
And when I was a little bit older
-- or around that same age actually--
I was teaching my little--
I was feeding my little sister.
She was maybe two or three.
My mother said, make sure
she eats her protein.
She was in a high chair
and I had this little fork
and I was putting the food in her mouth.
And I remember my mother said,
make sure she eats her protein.
And I knew if she didn't get her protein,
she would die within 24 hours
of a protein deficiency.
And, of course,
she didn't really want to eat it.
Every time I'd put it in her mouth,
she'd spit it out.
I was making like an airplane.
Here comes the protein.
She'd spit it out. So pretty soon
I was jamming it down her throat.
You got to eat your protein.
I don't want to be responsible
if you die of a protein deficiency.
But the idea here is that essentially,
from our families, from every institution
in our culture-- religion, education,
government, media, corporations--
we are injected with this notion,
with these official stories
that if we don't eat meat, we'll die.
We won't get enough protein
or enough calcium
if we don't eat enough dairy.
Even though there's no actual scientific
validity to any of these ideas,
they are the official stories
that are literally forced down
on our throats in many ways.
I know for sure
because I did it to my sister.
And I'm so glad to say actually that
my little sister is now a grandmother.
And she's a vegan.
And her daughter's a vegan.
And her grandson's a vegan.
And my mother's a vegan.
So they've somehow, at least
made some changes in their lives.
But to understand
the power of this program.
And for me, the only way
I could ever change was
that I had the opportunity
right out of college.
I left home, basically.
I went on a spiritual pilgrimage.
I thought, I try to get
to California.
And that's where everything's happening
is back in 1975.
And I ended up at a community
called The Farm in Tennessee,
which at that time was the largest
hippie commune in the world.
About 1,000 people were living there.
And they were eating--
what we would call today, a vegan diet.
They didn't eat any meat,
dairy products, or eggs.
They said they were vegetarians.
And I said,  why are you doing this?
And they said,
there's two main reasons.
One is there's a lot of people hungry
and we feed the grain
to animals while people starve.
And that doesn't seem right to us.
And the other reason is that do you know
what these poor animals go through?
And I kind of knew because
when I was about 13,
I'd gone away to a summer camp in Vermont
for a couple of years.
And they taught me
how to catch my own chicken.
How to put her down on the ground,
have my axe, cut her head off.
Put her through the scald tank
and eat the chickens.
And we even gathered around every year,
a dairy cow who wasn't giving
enough milk anymore.
And we had a gun and we just put it right
here and we just shot her in the head.
It was very shocking as a little kid,
13 years old, to not only witness this,
but to actually be participating in it.
And that's the whole thing.
Like meals, we don't just watch
adults eating meat and dairy.
They make us eat it, too.
We're forced to participate
in acts of enormous violence and killing.
Either eating the flesh of these animals,
and then also killing them.
But I never thought, even when we killed
this cow and it was so shocking,
just because the sheer amount actually,
of blood that came out of her.
I never thought for a moment
that what we were doing wasn't right.
I knew we were doing the right thing,
that God gave us these animals.
That they taste good.
That if you don't eat them, you will die
of a protein deficiency, and so forth.
So I knew what we were doing
was in alignment
with the harmony of the universe.
We were meant to eat animals.
So I knew there was nothing wrong with it.
But I was just shocked at the sheer
suffering that these cow--
The second year we were there, this cow.
We tried to bring her up to a place
to kill her and she broke the chain.
We were pulling her with a pickup truck
and she snapped it.
I could see, wow,
they really don't want to be killed.
I guess that'd be the same for me, too.
And I saw how they have to cut
their arteries right here.
That's really what happens to all animals.
I saw all this.
I saw directly.
The guy said, if you don't cut
these arteries immediately,
no one will eat the flesh.
It will be soggy. It will be disgusting.
You've got to bleed them out.
So as soon as she hit the ground,
after we shot her--
and feces and urine were pouring out--
then he cut her head off with this big,
long knife.
Blood was going all the way, 20 feet
in the air probably, from her heart.
Pumping it.
And he said, the heart has to pump
the blood out or the meat will be soggy.
So I realized, now after being a vegan
for 32 years, Madeleine and I traveled
to lots of operations,
factory farms, slaughter houses.
I just like to see
what's actually happening.
And the reason that animals suffer
so much actually, is that fact.
That we humans
don't want to eat soggy meat.
So you can't just kill an animal somehow,
come back a little later,
and then cut her up.
They have to be hanging upside down
by one leg, which they all are
-- chickens, pigs, cows, all the animals,
whatever they are-- lambs.
And then, this happens,
and they die by bleeding to death,
which is one of the worst
possible ways to die.
But we don't see that. We just get
these sanitized little pieces of flesh
in Saran wrap and Styrofoam.
And we don't know what that
poor animal went through.
And I saw this in this dairy
when I was 13 years old,
but I couldn't begin to question
the whole thing.
It was just so deeply ingrained in me.
So what I'm saying is it wasn't
until I got to The Farm in Tennessee
and there was 1,000 people,
probably 200 kids.
A lot of them were vegan from birth
and they were doing great.
They were not dying
of a protein deficiency.
I saw for myself, there they were.
They were doing fine.
And so when I asked them why they were
doing it, besides the world hunger.
He said, do you know what these animals
go through? The suffering?
And he just--
remember, just in a few sentences--
I got this little glimpse
of the massive hell realms
that we construct for animals
to kill 75 million animals a day.
These are animals that are stuck away
in these stinking sheds
where we don't see them.
But they're mutilated in horrific ways.
They're castrated without anesthesia.
Their noses are bashed.
Their tails are docked.
Their ears are clipped.
Their beaks are seared off,
just horrible mutilations,
and drugs, and violence.
It's just an extremely horrific life.
And then they're taken off and killed.
So seeing that, understanding that, and
then having this example of 1,000 people
that are just doing great
on a plant-based diet, that was it.
That was a no-brainer for me.
And I've never eaten meat again
in my life since that day in 1975.
And I heard many years later
when I met Madeleine--
she came over from Switzerland-
that she actually
has never eaten meat again
either starting that same month and year.
I'm not sure
if it was the same day in 1975.
And then about five years later,
I came to San Francisco.
And I learned more about
what dairy cows go through,
what hens go through
for eggs and for dairy products.
So I became a vegan in 1980.
I don't eat dairy and eggs either.
And a few years later after that,
I went to Korea and shaved my head,
became a Zen monk,
lived in a monastery there.
And I found myself, for the second time
in my life, in a community
that was practicing
what we would call today, veganism.
Again, they didn't call it that.
But there was no meat, no dairy,
no eggs, no wool, no silk, no leather.
You wouldn't even kill mosquitoes
if you could help it.
Kind of try to take them outside,
let them go.
There was this whole idea
of trying to live a life
as much as possible
of kindness and compassion.
And they've been doing this.
It wasn't this new California hippie idea
like I thought it was at The Farm.
I realized
this is an ancient spiritual teaching.
It goes back
many thousands of years, really.
But in this particular community
in South Korea,
they have been living
this way for 650 years.
So when I came back eventually,
to the United States, to California.
And I got my PhD at Berkeley,
and taught college, and so forth.
I realized that what veganism is
essentially an ancient teaching of ahimsa.
The Sanskrit word "ahimsa"
means nonviolence.
Or I think another way of saying it
is compassion.
Living my life as best as I can
to be an expression of kindness
or of nonviolence, or non-harmfulness.
And that this is really the foundational
wisdom in our society.
Not really in our society,
but in our species.
It's definitely not in our society.
But in our species that
every religious teaching on this planet,
if you go deeply into what
the great religions were talking about,
you could probably boil it down
to one sentence, which would be
something like, whatever you most want
for yourself, give that to others.
This basic idea, whatever I most want
for myself, to give that to others.
If I want to be loved, then to be loving.
If I want to have an abundant life,
then be generous.
If I want to be free, let other's be free.
Free others.
But we're born and raised in a culture
that we don't get that.
We are taught, essentially, by the rituals
in our lives, by meals
and many other ways, too, but I think
meals are the most foundational way,
to manipulate, control, dominate, oppress,
exploit, get what we can, be separate.
And I think that now it's the time for us,
as a species, and as individuals
within our culture,
to question the official stories.
And the most powerful way
I think anyone can do this
is to question the food system.
Because animals who are abused for food
really suffer enormously at our hands.
But there's many other levels
of this suffering.
Actually, when I came back here-- and I'll
just finish this little thing up here.
So I started with Madeleine
traveling around the United States
after teaching college for a number of
years, and doing lectures and concerts.
I'm a musician also, and composer.
I just started getting this vision.
And I said, someone's going to write
a book about the big picture
of our culture's mistreatment
of animals for food.
It will be great to read that book
when it comes out.
The years went by
and the book never came out.
Finally Madeleine said, Will,
if you want to read that book,
you'll have to write it yourself.
Which I didn't want to hear,
but I spent five years writing the book
that ended up being The World Peace Diet.
The basic idea is that besides the outer
ramifications of our food choices
that people have written books about,
like the three big ones are
it's not good for your health,
it's not good for the environment,
and it's not good for the animals
who suffer so much because of this.
But the inner ramifications of this,
what it does to us
psychologically and so forth.
So basically, what I'd like to do here
in the next few minutes
is talk about these ramifications.
First, the outer ones.
The outer ramifications, environmentally--
there's a whole chapter.
I really could talk
a long time about this.
But just to sum it up briefly.
We see this. We actually have now,
in our 17th year of living full-time
in a rolling home, a house on wheels.
It's called an RV,
with solar panels on the roof.
We get most of our energy
from the sun.
And as we travel around, most of
North America has been really enslaved.
The land has been converted into huge
fields that grow primarily two crops,
genetically engineered corn
and genetically engineered soybeans.
That's most of what you see.
There's also some other grains.
But probably 80% to 85%, to 90% to 95%
depending on which grain it is,
of this enormous amount of crops
that are grown are not fed to people.
They're fed to animals who you don't see.
They're hyperconfined in these stinking
sheds by tens or hundreds of thousands.
But it's an incredibly inefficient system.
Environmentally it's devastating.
The primary driving force
behind global warming,
behind species extinction,
behind water and air pollution
environmentally is this system
of animal agriculture.
Because it takes so much land
to grow all this grain.
This land is doused with chemicals,
herbicides, pesticides,
fungicides, all kinds of things.
So it's a war against nature. No species
is allowed to live there except one.
So nature's trying to make diversity
and we're killing off everything
except soybeans.
So all the plants, all the animals,
all that runoff into the water
creating huge dead zones,
beautification of the water
where nothing can live there anymore
because of all the chemical fertilizers
that are used on this land.
And then, the animals are very inefficient
at converting,
essentially very healthy things--
fiber, amino acids, proteins,
carbohydrates, lipids,
all the different fats.
They convert that into what?
Saturated fat, cholesterol,
acidifying animal protein,
and huge amounts of sewage,
which end up, again,
polluting both surface water
and groundwater.
One large pig operation, for example,
creates more sewage
than the entire New York City.
And yet, it's basically unregulated.
These big factory farms
do not want to be regulated.
And so they're not regulated because
the government and the industry
is so corrupt, essentially.
So we have a situation where
massive amounts of direct pollution
are being caused, as well as huge amounts
of methane and nitrous oxide,
both of which are now recognized
to be much more powerful greenhouse gases
than carbon dioxide are being gassed out
all the time from animal agriculture.
As well as the fact that
we're cutting down huge amounts of forest.
Already not only temperate forests,
but rainforests.
Rainforests right now,
like in the Amazonian basin,
we're losing, by a conservative estimate,
about an acre per second of rainforest
is being cut down or burned.
And the primary driving motivation
for that is people want to eat meat,
dairy products, and eggs.
Because the big cash crop now is soybeans.
And this is not soybeans for tofu.
This is soybeans for feeding
factory-farmed or confined pigs,
cows, chickens, and surprisingly fish.
Fish eat a huge amount of grain.
Most people don't realize that,
but I've seen these places.
So we're seeing a devastation,
when you cut down an acre of rainforest,
like we're doing an acre per second,
you're not just cutting down some trees.
We're cutting down whole ecosystems
that took millions of years to develop.
They are incredibly complex, precious--
it's insane what we're doing.
But just to grow soybeans to feed
of these cows, and pigs,
and chickens and fish, who are then
fed to humans, and fed to each other.
Huge amount of fish is fed to pigs
and cows to fatten them up.
So besides that, the other thing is
the devastation of the oceans.
People don't realize it,
it's not really covered.
None of this stuff is covered
in the mass media very well
because, obviously, we have
a very wealthy pharmaceutical
and food system that doesn't want
people to understand these things.
But the oceans are being basically,
clear cut, in a sense, of species of fish.
The largest fishes, like tuna, salmon,
many of the other ones,
are teetering on the brink of collapse.
There aren't many fish left.
So for that reason, in the United States
now, 2/3 of the fish
that we're eating are factory farmed.
And it's called aquaculture.
I've been to this operations.
There's both offshore aquaculture
and onshore.
They're both environmentally devastating.
I don't have time to go into it,
but just having that many fish
concentrated in one area,
huge amounts of feces, lots of
chemicals, pesticides, herbicides,
and antibiotics are fed to these animals.
And then there's also onshore operations,
which I have seen those direct
These gigantic swimming pools.
And I look into them, I thought
there was nothing there but black water.
They look like they're just swimming pools
filled with black water.
But I realized, as I kept looking,
that they're packed with fish.
The fish are just crammed in there.
They're swimming in their own feces.
That's why the water's black.
And the workers are dumping in lots of
antibiotics and so forth.
So it's very, very toxic stuff,
actually, to be eating.
And fish concentrate toxins in their flesh
literally tens or hundreds of thousands,
sometimes even millions of times more
than is in the surrounding water
for a variety of reasons.
Probably because they're breathing
the waters as well.
So the underlying message here is that
environmentally, animal agriculture
is devastating this planet
far more than anything.
According to scientists,
there's no disagreement on this.
If everyone in the world ate
the kind of diet that people
in the United States eat, we would need
probably between 2 and 1/2 and 3 Earth's
to even begin to sustain that.
So in the United States, in particular,
we're eating way more,
in a sense, than our share.
There's no greater way to reduce
our environmental footprint
than to reduce the amount of meat, dairy
products, and eggs that we're eating.
The amount of water is typically, again,
by conservative estimate, about 30 to 1.
In other words, 1 person eating
a vegan diet, excuse me, 30 people
eating a vegan diet or 1 person eating a
standard American diet in terms of water.
It's about 15 to 20 to
in terms of petroleum.
And it's about 20 to 1 in terms of land
and pollution in general.
About 20 to 1.
So just basically understanding that
from the environmental point of view.
From the cultural point of view, just
briefly, the fact is, as I said earlier,
we're feeding most of the grain to
animals while people are going hungry.
So we have a situation today, which to me,
it should be a cause for celebration.
Which is the fact that we live
on an incredibly abundant Earth.
An Earth that can easily support
everybody. We're not taught that.
We're growing enough food right now to
feed between 12 and 15 billion people.
Every year we grow plenty of food
to feed everybody,
twice as many people than we even have.
But we have this message all the time,
there's not enough to eat,
people are starving.
A billion people are starving
or malnourished.
That's true, about 900 million.
But roughly a billion people.
And so in that end of the bell curve,
the poorest billion.
And on the other end of the bell curve,
the richest billion are also suffering,
ironically from diseases that come from
feeding most of the grains and legumes
that are grown to animals, who then
convert it to what I said earlier,
to unhealthy substances.
So the people in our culture,
the wealthy cultures today,
are suffering from epidemics
as you all know.
I don't have to go into this,
of heart disease, strokes,
cancers of various kinds-- primarily
prostate, breast, and colon cancer,
diverticulitis, arthritis, obesity,
diabetes, autoimmune diseases,
liver disease, kidney disease.
All of these diseases are definitively
linked to eating animal foods and diets
that are high in animal foods.
So this is, again, enriching
a tiny minority of people.
The bottom line for us, as human beings,
it's sowing the seeds of conflict and war.
Because you cannot have a situation
where you have some people who are
literally eating so high off the hog
that they're taking most of the resources,
most of the land, most of the water.
I mean, water has become the new oil.
It's very serious, the water shortages.
It takes huge amounts of water
to irrigate these crops,
to feed the animals, to slaughter them.
So they're taking
a gigantic amount of resources while
other people see their babies starving.
That kind of inequality and inequity
is the driving force
behind global conflict and war.
Again, which enriches a few people
making a lot of weapons.
But for us, as people, it's not good.
It's not a good idea.
Besides the war and violence
that is inherent in this whole system.
And you've got to remember also,
that it's very easy for us
in the industrialized countries of the
world. We have high-powered economies.
We can easily drive up the price of grain
and feed it to animals to eat meat,
dairy products, and eggs
to a point that's too high
in the global grain markets for people
in less powerful economies to afford.
They just cannot afford it
and they starve.
And it's directly because we are buying it
and feeding it to our animals.
And they're not going hungry.
They always have plenty to eat.
So we have to understand
the underlying force here.
And the other thing that
is vitally important understand
is that in order to be killing
75 million animals a day for food,
we have to have a whole army
of our brothers and sisters
who have to do the work.
They have to stand there
and stab animals all day.
Or electroshock them, or mutilate them.
And these workers have the highest rates
of work-related injuries.
They have the highest rates of suicide,
drug addiction, alcoholism,
spousal abuse, and child abuse.
According to psychologists, they suffer--
it's a new disease. They just recently
put a name to, it's perpetrator-induced
traumatic stress disorder.
They are paid to be perpetrators
of horrific violence.
This is work that brings out
the worst in them.
And they may not be typically
violent people to begin with.
But after just stabbing animals all day,
soon they go home
and start doing the same thing
to people, and their families,
and communities, and neighborhoods.
And so like Martin Luther King said,
I think this is one of-- again,
the essential wisdoms of ourselves,
as human beings. We know this is true.
He said, violence anywhere
hurts everybody everywhere
because we're all interconnected.
And what veganism is about,
essentially is the same teaching,
which is compassion and kindness anywhere
blesses everyone, everywhere
because we're all interconnected.
We understand that.
I think in our bones we know
that our welfare is interconnected.
The more that we live our lives
so that we're aware that the ripples
that radiate out from our lives,
from our behavior,
from our words and actions,
what we pay for and buy, that that,
instead of causing misery, and terror,
and pain, and suffering, and violence
to others, to do the best we can that
it causes abundance, and sustainability,
and joy, and creativity.
That that's going to come back to us.
Because what I said earlier,
whatever we most want for ourselves,
we should give to others.
Another way of saying that is,
whatever you sow, you will reap.
Whatever you put out, it will come back.
We are born and raised in a culture
that does not get that. We pretend
that we can sow seeds of violence
and have it never come back.
And yet, what I believe is
the great adventure, as I said earlier,
for us to go on is to realize that these
animals, and also the starving people.
But in general, especially the animals
who we're causing so much suffering to.
It's not just the animals-- pigs,
cows, chickens that suffer.
It's also wildlife.
We're having right now a mass extinction
of species caused by the loss of habitat,
of elephants, and giraffes, and wolves,
and coyotes, are prairie dogs,
and pretty much
the entire ecosystems of this planet.
The animals are losing their habitat
because of this.
And so they are suffering as well.
So the point is that these animals
who we are causing so much suffering to,
they do not retaliate.
So we, essentially, think,
well, they don't retaliate, so we can do
whatever we want to them.
We can hyperconfine them, mutilate them,
kill them, and so forth.
We don't realize that our violence
towards them always retaliates.
It does always come back.
It comes back in these ways
that we're not aware of it.
It comes back as heart disease
and physical diseases of various kinds,
psychological diseases, cultural
diseases, environmental disease.
And so I think what we're seeing today is
an awakening of our inherent wisdom
to realize these interconnections.
And actually, begin to understand
how the violence does come back.
So now, after having talked about
some of the outer ramifications,
I'd like to talk about the inner ones
just briefly. Basically, like I said,
in order to be killing 75 million animals
every day for food, we have to have
a culture where everyone votes for that,
pays for that, and doesn't question that.
We take out our wallet and pay for that.
What kind of a mentality
do we have to have?
We have been injected
with this mentality by our culture.
And it's not in our best interest.
I think the greatest gift we can give
to ourselves, and to our loved ones,
and to our culture is to understand
these ideas, and to be able to question.
Did you see the movie,
it was called The Matrix?
In the beginning, Neo--
it's been a long time since I saw it.
In the beginning, Neo gets
captured by these government agents.
And they-- in order to track him, I guess
they inject a bug into him, or something.
And then his friends get it out of him.
That's one of the first things they do.
And that's what we're talking about.
All of us have been injected
with this toxic program of seeing beings
merely as things to be eaten and used.
And it really is far more devastating
than we realize. And the greatest gift
I think we can give to each other is
to help each other get that out of us.
Because if we can do that as individuals,
we can create a culture that is
at a whole much higher level
in terms of our wisdom,
our ability to live sustainably
with freedom, and joy, and compassion.
Because the basic mentality
is injected into us by the food rituals
that we're obliged to engage in
just growing up here.
Number one
it's a mentality of reductionism.
The subtext of every meal,
what's basically being taught
in a meal ritual
is certain beings are not beings.
Certain beings are merely things.
They're commodities, you buy and sell.
When you're eating bacon,
for example, we're eating pigs.
We don't think of it we're eating pigs.
We're just eating bacon.
Pork bellies are sold as commodities,
like you sell--whatever.
Rocks and machines.
And so we don't see a pig as a being
with interest,with wisdom, with emotions,
who loves her babies
and wants the best for them
and wants to care for them.
And lives in a community
with other animals of the same species
that have complex social relationships.
We just see a piece of meat.
Can you imagine really, the devastation
this does to our own basic intelligence?
It's incredible.
It just slams-- the basic intelligence
of this cultures is wilted and crushed
by being raised in a culture where
we're forced to see a being as a thing.
Merely a thing.
So that's the foundation.
It's the reductionism
and commodification of life.
It's also, essentially,
a mentality of exclusion.
We practice every day, just excluding.
I don't care about them. They're
just things. We get very good at this.
There's an old German saying,
'bung macht den Meister.'
That means "practice makes the master."
Whatever we practice, we'll get good at.
So we get very good at that.
Another very important thing
to understand is that it's also
essentially a mentality
of elitism and privilege.
The subtext of every meal is
certain beings are inherently superior.
Other beings are inherently inferior.
Those who are superior
use, exploit, dominate, and control
however they want the inferior beings.
And the way that is enacted is
through eating them.
Eating their flesh.
Eating their secretions.
Dominating, humiliating, destroying them.
They're stealing from them
in every possible way.
Stealing their purposes, their babies,
their time, their life, everything.
They have nothing.
We steal everything.
We are the powerful ones.
They have nothing.
This is what we're taught
at a very deep level.
Sociologists say the biggest problem
in our culture
-- and I think this is obvious--
is this massive inequity.
Some people are so rich
they don't know what to do
with their money.
Other people can't even get enough to eat.
And yet, every meal reinforces inequity,
inequality, privilege, and elitism.
That's the fundamental teaching.
How can we expect as a culture to evolve
to the point where we actually create
the possibility for peace, and freedom,
and justice, and equality
when every meal-- and meals are
our most powerful connection with nature,
with our culture, with the universe--
is the opposite of that?
We have to look at the food
and transform the food.
If we transform the food,
everything else will go.
That's the hardest thing.
That's why most people don't want to come
to a lecture like this.
They're like, I don't want to hear
about this. It's too threatening.
I may be very smart,
but I don't want to look at that.
We have to be willing to look, I think,
at what's hardest to look at.
And that's the great joy,
I think, of this whole thing.
The underlying message.
I'm feeling like--
I'm going to wrap it up here.
The message that I feel
called to give here is not so much
a negative message.
It might sound kind of negative.
I talk about all these bad things
that are happening.
But the underlying message
is very positive
because we can transform our culture.
We can transform our lives relatively
easily once we understand this.
If we change our food, we change
at the deepest level.
That's the fundamental, primal level
of indoctrination in our culture,
of connection to the Earth.
And so what I've just been saying,
the reductionism, commodification,
exclusion, and predation is another.
We're taught essentially
that we're predatory.
A predator is the exact opposite of what
the spiritual--every religion, the idea
of someone who is evolved spiritually,
or ethically, or intellectually, morally,
is someone who looks with eyes to help
others to bless, to create a better world.
And yet, the predator is one,
how can I harm you for my benefit?
How can I destroy and take from you?
This is the antithesis.
And yet, we're taught
essentially that we're predators.
Why do we wonder why we create
predatory economic systems?
And then the other powerful thing,
I think, important to understand is
that the subtext of every meal is the
repression and domination and exploitation
of what I refer to as Sophia.
Sophia is the feminine principle.
The feminine wisdom within I think
all of us, whether we're men or women,
we have within us living
a feminine wisdom.
And that is the wisdom
that yearns to protect life.
A mother, when she gives birth to a baby,
this wisdom just kicks in
and she loves that baby,
she wants to protect that little baby.
And we want to protect
the life of the Earth.
We want to protect the rainforest.
We want to have a world to give
to the future generations.
Sophia is the Greek goddess of wisdom,
this ancient idea that lives
within all of us of a wisdom
that is within all of us.
And we have to understand that animal
agriculture, from the very beginning,
it was about men
dominating female animals.
And today it's the same.
It's the female animals
in animal agriculture that suffer
by far the worst.
They're impregnated against their will
after 9 months of-- in the case of cows,
giving birth to a baby.
Whether the dairy's organic or not,
it doesn't matter. They steal the baby.
They impregnate her again
on the rape rack.
They steal the baby again,
impregnate her again.
A female cow, for example,
would live normally 25 years.
After 4, 5, at the most 6 years
on any dairy, organic or not.
She's killed because her production
starts declining.
So this is incredible violence
towards the feminine.
It's about dominating, exploiting
not just female beings,
but female reproductive organs--uteruses,
vaginas, mammary glands--exploiting them.
You couldn't have animal agriculture
without the complete domination
of the reproductive organs
and cycles of animals--
pigs, mammals in general, birds, and fish.
So what we have to realize is
that when we do this on the outer level,
we do the same thing on the inner level.
That our own feminine wisdom is repressed
when we repress these animals.
And so we have, today, a culture
where Sophia, our natural wisdom
that celebrates and protects life,
is so suppressed as little children
being forced to eat meat, dairy products,
and eggs that we have created a culture
where we can be doing
what I've been talking about.
We can destroy the oceans,
and no one cares.
We cut down the rainforest,
and everybody goes, well, so what?
Have people starving.
Have corporations that, literally,
are targeting our children with
advertising campaigns that use violence,
and pornography, and all kinds of things.
And we just let that happen.
And I think what we're seeing today,
which is very positive,
is the resurrection,
in many ways, of Sophia.
We see that Sophia is caring and kindness
and compassion and protectiveness.
And that, I think, is what's underlying
the vegan movement.
I think a lot of the movements that we see
to protect life is the same thing.
So those are some of the main ideas
in the beginning of the book.
Trying to zip through
a few other main points.
There's a chapter
about the history of all this,
which is incredibly important
to understand.
I don't have time,
but it is in the book.
But the basic idea is that we've only
been owning animals as property for food.
It's called herding.
We've only been herding animals
for about 8,000 to 10,000 years.
So it's a relatively new thing.
It was the last revolution I believe
this culture ever went through.
And it was a revolution of reductionism,
of reducing beings to things.
And what happened simultaneously with this
revolution, it took thousands of years.
It was a very slow revolution, probably
took 7,000 or 8,000 years.
But by the time historic period emerged,
which began like 3,000 years ago--
we see it well in place we have a wealthy,
elite class that comes out of this.
They're wealthy and elite because
they own capital. What's capita?
Anyone know what capital,
where that word comes from--the root?
AUDIENCE: Heads.
WILL TUTTLE: Right, head.
Yeah, capitalism and capital,
it means literally head in Latin,
of sheep, goats, cows.
They have the wealth.
They invented two more institutions.
One is--the ancient Sanskrit word
for it is "gavyaa".
That word is translated as "war." It means
literally, the desire for more cows.
So this wealthy elite that emerged, they
learned that if they saw some other guy
that had a lot of cows, it was the first
get-rich quick scheme.
I'll just go attack him.
I'll get a bunch of my shepherds
and we make soldiers out of them.
We attack there. And then,
if we win the war-- we had the first
wars that ever happened on the planet.
If we win that war, then we get rich.
We get all that capital.
Becomes my capital.
And the people who happen to be in that--
affiliated with that rich guy--
we own animals.
Now it's a short step to owning people.
So the second institution
that was invented was slavery.
So now we enslave these people.
They become our property.
So they just took the women.
They started  impregnating them
like they do their cows, and just making
as many slave babies as possible.
The males, they just castrated them
like they did the livestock.
And they became slaves
that work in the fields.
And we had a beginning,
of a very warlike, violent society.
Women, also their status was reduced.
They became--unfortunately,
bought and sold like chattel property.
And this culture spread throughout
the whole Eastern Mediterranean,
to the Northern Mediterranean, to Central
Asia, to Europe, came over here.
And then spread from here. It's been
spreading over the entire planet.
It's still spreading through Monsanto,
Cargill, Burger King, McDonald's,
Kentucky Fried Chicken, Smithfield Foods,
this whole--I call it the military,
industrial meat, medical,
pharmaceutical, media complex.
It's this vast complex. And it gets
very wealthy on this whole thing.
But it's not good for us-- the people,
the planet, the future generations,
animals, ecosystems.
This is the thing we have to realize.
If we're really serious about creating
a world that reflects what I believe
is our natural intelligence,
to understand that the food program
suppresses that so much.
To question the food program
and our intelligence can come back.
So there's a lot more in there.
There's a chapter that goes into the fact
that whatever problems we have
in the outer world,
we also see in the inner world.
And whatever problems that we're doing--
the problems we have in the outer world,
we're inflicting on animals. So we have,
for example, an obesity epidemic.
And what do we do to animals for food?
They're sold by the pound, so we have
great technologies
to make them very fat, very quickly.
So we're sowing the seeds of obesity
in billions of animals and we get obese.
We sow the seeds of osteoporosis
and we got osteoporosis.
We force these animals to overproduce
milk and eggs, and so that sucks
the calcium out of their bones.
Dairy cows, they say for example,
after they kill them,
and only five years old,
the slaughter house workers say they can
break their bones in their bare hands
they have such severe osteoporosis.
Because they're sucking all this calcium
out of their bodies for the milk.
The same thing with chickens.
There's a lot of calcium in eggs.
We force these diseases
on these animals and we get them.
We force many social diseases,
psychological diseases.
We find the pharmaceutical industry
making enormous profits on drugs.
Let me close with this.
The three main profit centers
for the pharmaceutical industry
are huge amounts of drugs for animals.
There's over 10,000 different drugs,
hormones, antibiotics.
Now about 85% to 90% of antibiotics
are used on animals, forced on them.
So that's one of their big profit
centers is that, drugs to these animals.
And the second big one is people eat
the flesh of these animals and dairy
products and eggs, so they get
the diseases that I was talking earlier.
So they need medications for cancer,
heart disease, diabetes, and all that.
So they get huge profits there.
Then the third one--
the biggest one actually of all three
is the profits for people with depression,
and pain, and insomnia, and anxiety,
and panic attacks, and all these things.
And they eat again,
the flesh and secretion of animals
that are experiencing, what?
Depression, insomnia, pain, fear, terror,
despair, anxiety, and so forth.
So as we sow, so shall we reap.
And yet, we have a tiny, wealthy elite
getting very rich off of that
reaping of the violence
and the whole thing.
There's a chapter that goes
into the basic-- it's called
"The Intelligence
of Human Physiology."
What are our bodies
actually designed to eat?
That's the longest chapter
in the book. And  it's in there.
But the beauty of that is just
to realize that all of us have been given
the gift of a physical body that doesn't
require any animal to suffer to feed us.
And yet, we're born into a culture
where we're taught, essentially forced,
to take that gift we've been given
and throw it back
in the face
of the benevolent creator and say,
I'm going to stab and kill animals
anyway to feed them.
And we reap a lot of negative
repercussions from that.
So to really learn,
what are we designed to eat?
And again, I could talk
a long time about that.
So there's many other ramifications
of this in other chapters
in The World Peace Diet,
but that's the basic idea.
And I think I'm pretty much out of time
here for-- yeah, that's perfect.
So I have a few minutes, perhaps,
for questions.
Perhaps if there are any questions.
And also, we do have copies
of The World Peace
-- actually, The World Peace Diet
is over here. It's a great price.
And it was printed on
100%post-consumer recycled paper.
So no trees were cut down
for The World Peace Diet.
And we have the audio books.
We have CDs of music.
I play the piano and compose music.
And art cards and art prints
of Madeleine's paintings.
And a sign-up sheet
if you want to get on her email list.
We have, also, information about
The World Peace Diet Facilitator Training
and Mastery Program if you want to
understand this more in-depth.
We've a whole network of World Peace Diet
study groups around the North America--
actually, around the world. There's other
cultures as well that are doing this.
And the book's being translated
into many languages also.
So we're not just talking
about these ideas. But the idea is
to actually try to live our lives
in alignment with our own inner wisdom.
So that means, if we're eating
a regular diet, to move
toward becoming a vegetarian. If we're
vegetarian, to move toward becoming vegan.
If we're a vegan, to move toward becoming
a vegan educator or advocate in some way,
to help spread this idea. Because I think
the more we understand these ideas
and can bring our lives into alignment
with those ideas, the better chance
we'll have to actually pass a planet
on to our children that'll be healthy.
And we'll be able to live healthy
and happy lives ourselves.
Because the underlying idea
is these universal understandings,
these universal teachings that
we are all interconnected.
That all life is interrelated. And that
as we bless others, we will be blessed.
So does anyone have a question briefly?
I only have a couple minutes here.
And if you want to ask a question,
please go to this microphone.
AUDIENCE: Thanks very much for coming
and speaking, and for your work.
My question is--
there are several parts to it.
But the basic part is why veganism,
in a sense that why does one have to go
that far to break free of the lack
of consciousness in the current system?
So there have been cultures for
thousands of years that hunted animals,
but did not inflict the kinds of harm that
are caused by modern day agribusiness.
I've heard of Native American practices
of saying a prayer and asking forgiveness
from an animal that they had hunted,
which has a degree of consciousness to it.
Which may not be as nonviolent.
Also wondering if there are some people
who actually require animal protein
for some reason, for particular reasons?
People who have chickens at home and get
their eggs, for example.
It's now part of a larger system.
WILL TUTTLE: Right.
A bunch of questions there.
Most of all of those are addressed
in The World Peace Diet.
I'm a little concerned on how long
I can answer these questions
in a short amount of time.
But basically, I would say
moving toward veganism--
veganism, to me, is a mentality
of radical inclusion. It's saying
I'm going to include all living beings in
the sphere of my kindness and compassion.
And it's also, I think, in many ways,
coming home to our essential true nature
where I look with eyes that see beings
rather than seeing things.
And I think anything less than that,
I mean, it's an ideal.
It's a very high ideal. So I just think
it's the goal to move toward.
You can be living on the outer level
of a totally vegan life, like no meat,
no dairy, no eggs, no going to the zoo,
no going to the circus,
not buying leather, all these things.
But still, I get angry with people
or I judge them, or whatever.
That's still not vegan.
The idea is really, I think, a very
sophisticated level in a sense to evolve
emotionally, intellectually,
and spiritually to the point
where we're living a life as much as
possible of kindness and compassion.
So I think that there maybe have been
other cultures in the past that did
certain things. I'm not sure.
We don't know what happened on 9/11.
There's so many arguments about
what happened a 1000, or 10,000 years ago.
People said that people
ate a lot of meat in the old days,
and there may be some truth to that.
A lot of recent research coming out from
non-meat-eating anthropologists is that
actually cultures that we thought
were mostly eating meat actually
were not eating mostly meat.
They were actually eating
mostly plant-based foods.
And whether there's a necessity
to eat meat, I don't think that's true.
I've talked a lot of doctors
and researchers who disagree with that.
That there's any human
being on this planet
that needs to eat meat for any reason.
Animals do not contribute any nutrient
that they didn't get from plants
originally.
All the amino acids,
all the vitamins, minerals, fiber,
essential fatty acids, carbohydrates,
all originates with plants.
The only two exceptions of that
that we're aware of at this point
are vitamin D, which is essentially
from the sun, and vitamin B12,
which is created by bacteria which
normally we'd get in the water.
But since we chlorinate it and kill
all the bacteria, and perhaps also
through foods in general. But essentially,
animals don't contribute anything.
I mean, the animals tend to concentrate
toxins in their flesh, which we're getting
when we eat them.
As well as the meta-- the whole chapter
called "The Metaphysical Toxins"
of eating terror, and fear, and pain.
I mean, if I'm convinced in my mind
that I'm not going to be healthy
unless I eat something, then sure.
I could convince myself
that I was sick so I could tell my mother,
I don't feel good today.
I don't want to go to school.
Pretty soon I felt terrible because
I didn't want to lie to her.
We have to realize that the placebo
effect is very powerful.
What our minds believe
will be the reality.
But instead of looking at the past
to determine our behavior,
why don't we look at the future,
see the kind of world we want to build,
and move forward, move toward that?
We can feed everyone on a plant-based die
on a fraction of the land,
with a fraction of the pollution.
Let's do it.
Why do we have to look back
and say, well, they did this.
People look at animals and say,
animals eat meat.
But we don't say, well,
no animal is building computers.
But we're building computers. We
don't have to look to these other things.
The idea is to look ahead
and look what we want to create.
I have a whole chapter
in The World Peace Diet
of dealing with
all the rationalizations and objections
that naturally come up
when people hear these ideas.
We have certain ones that are told to us.
Jesus ate meat, so it must be OK.
The Indians were very spiritual.
They ate meat, so it must be good.
Or plants have feelings, too.
If you eat your carrots, I eat my cow,
it's the same thing.
They all have feelings.
There's certain standard objections
that just keep our Sophia repressed.
and the other thing I'll just mention,
which I think is fascinating.
Have you heard of Joseph Campbell,
the well-known mythologist? He gave
a fascinating series of interviews
to Bill Moyer back in the '80s, I think.
And it was so interesting because I used
to teach college classes in mythology,
and I read a lot of Campbell's books.
At one point Bill Moyer asked him,
he said, so, Joseph.
Human beings seem to be the myth-creating
animal. We create myths.
We create these stories that tell us how
things happened
and why they happened, and all of that.
What is the main reason?
If you could say, what is one main reason
that human beings create myths,
what would it be?
And Joseph Campbell said,
the one main reason that human beings
create myths, these stories that explain
reality, was to rationalize and justify
killing animals for food.
I went, wow.
Because this is something that's always
been very hard for us to deal with.
And we've created an elaborate land of
milk and honey, and Krishna and the Cow,
and all kinds of things to explain
and rationalize this behavior.
But I think we can get beyond that level.
Thank you. Great question.
Really appreciate it.
AUDIENCE: With your permission,
I'd like to look back
to the past again if you don't mind.
So you mentioned that herding agriculture
is a relatively recent invention, and has
a lot of not very positive effects on
human health, and welfare, and so forth.
There are actually a number
of anthropologists who have looked at
agricultural more generally,
like Jared Diamond, and so forth.
And basically, concluded
that it was a terrible idea.
That not just animals, but agriculture
in general, cereal grains and so forth.
I'm just wondering what your feeling is
about that, the general aspect
of pre-agricultural versus
post-agricultural health
not just looking at animals.
WILL TUTTLE: Yeah.
That's a great question.
Basically, these people
that are writing this,
I don't think they have
The World Peace Diet view.
They're meat eaters.
Jared Diamond's a meat eater.
And so there's a tendency to look at
things from that perspective of,
we're meat eaters
and this is how we see it.
And to sort of say all agriculture is
sort of bad. It's unnatural.
We should go back kind of to living
just gathering like people did.
But I think, basically,
there's two kinds of agriculture.
They're very different.
And we have a tendency to just--
someone says, I'm a farmer.
Oh, you're a farmer.
What kind of a farmer?
Because there's plant agriculture's
and there's animal agriculture.
And from the very beginning, plant
agriculture was essentially women's work.
And it was work that was working
essentially with nature.
I mean, you plant something
and this miracle happens.
You plant one seed
and a thousand seeds come.
And then you plant one of those
and a thousand more.
Working with the abundance of nature.
You're working with cycles of nature.
And with the essential abundance
and fertility of nature.
Whereas, with animal agriculture,
was essentially men's work.
And the animals were always fighting back.
They were always resisting.
They did not want to be killed,
to have their babies stolen.
They did not want to be raped
and impregnated against their will.
So men had to violate them.
They had to hit them.
They had to rape them.
They had to hold them down
and brand them, just incredible violence.
And so we created a culture
mainly of meat-eating where the grains--
we're feeding the grains to these animals.
But all of us know, if we were to go--
anyone who goes into a well-tended
and loved garden of vegetables,
it's a wonderful place to be.
It's beautiful. There's biodiversity.
There's life happening there.
Any one of us went into a slaughterhouse,
it's like, let me out of here.
It's a horrible, terrible thing.
So I think we have to realize
that these are fundamentally
different ways of agriculture.
And I think that we are here, personally,
to work in harmony with nature,
to create gardens.
And the new forms of gardening
that are developing-- veganic gardening
where we use no animal inputs at all,
food forests, which--
there's some people in Canada,
we were just visiting them,
and other places that are building
these food forests
where you're growing huge amounts of food.
And it doesn't even look like
it's anything there.
They have fruit trees and then
other vegetables, and flowers,
and things just all going together
and creating these ecosystems.
As we understand these things
more and more, we realize
we can grow enough food to feed everyone
on a fraction of the land.
If people ate a plant-based diet,
we could have forests coming back,
the rainforests coming back, the oceans
coming back. We wouldn't need to kill fish
Cows, for example, are eating more fish
in the US than human beings are
because we're feeding the fish
to the cows, so they'll give more milk.
And it's an incredibly violent,
devastating project.
And we're doing plant agriculture the way
we do animal agriculture.
Since we're an animal agriculture
society essentially,
we do plant agriculture
with monocropping and violence,
with all these chemicals,
and herbicides, and fungicides.
It's a war against nature.
We're killing everything else.
We don't want any other animals.
Any black birds, we try to kill them off.
So we're looking with the lens
of animal agriculture at all agriculture.
And you're right. I mean, he's right.
It's terrible.
But that's because we did animal culture.
We didn't do plant agriculture properly.
And I think we have the chance to do that.
But much love to you all.
Thanks so much for being here,
and I'm happy to sign books
if anyone wants to get a book,
or an audio book, or music,
or cards, or anything. It's a great deal.
I mean, you can't go wrong.
And yeah, I'm happy to answer
any questions anybody has also.
So please stay around.
Bunch of love to you.
Thanks, again. Thanks for coming.
Thank you.